Hey guys, uh, am I audible?
Can you see the screen? Of course you can.
So yeah, thank you, thank you for coming. I know it
is, uh, clashing with Werner's
keynote, so we appreciate even
more that you are here and chose us.
Uh, with that, I'll
give it to Ed.
Before that, sorry,
I forgot to introduce myself.
I'm Rahul Popot. I'm the senior solution architect
at AWS, um,
been with AWS for over close to 6 years
now, based out of New Jersey.
And yeah, uh, I'm with my colleague,
Ed. Hi,
good afternoon, everyone.
Uh, my name's Ed Schaeffer, also a solutions architect
at AWS.
Uh, been with AWS for a little over
5 years based out of the, the Philadelphia
area, um, and this afternoon
we're excited to talk to you guys about,
uh, how to build AI agents with,
uh, with serverless strands and,
uh, MCP servers.
Uh,
throughout the, uh, session today,
we'll talk a little bit about what Agentic
AI is, um, how you
can build AI agents using
strands,
how to integrate, uh, external
and third-party tools.
Uh, some deployment options,
uh, we'll be focusing on serverless technologies
today, um, walk through
some of the architecture and workflows,
and, uh, we'll get into
a live coding demo
which
we've made enough sacrifices and,
uh,
and prayers to the demo gods today, so
hopefully everything works out,
um. So,
yeah, let's start off of,
you know, understanding why do we need an AI agent,
right? LLMs are are pretty powerful.
Um, we can get a lot of things done with
uh large language models today,
but they're passive,
right? Out of the box, an LLM
will.
Take your request,
generate some response,
document,
texts.
Picture,
uh, audio, whatever it is, um,
and give it back to you, but it's
limited in the sense of,
uh, of its knowledge
and LLM
is only aware of
the data and the knowledge that
was fed into it during the training process,
so it's, it's just a single snapshot,
uh, point in time,
um. It doesn't
have any awareness of what's going
on in the world or
necessarily context about your specific use
case. So that's where
AI agents um come into play.
They can help,
uh, take action,
where an LLM is normally
locked in its silo.
An agent will allow
your model to
reach out to access external
systems,
to access external APIs,
um.
To conduct actions and
perform tasks, uh, on your behalf and
really give you the opportunity to build
more robust, uh, workflows
and
really make your life a lot easier.
Is, is anyone, um,
just a show of hands, has anyone used,
uh, any AI agents or automated
workflows
recently?
Nice. Few hands, few hands, awesome.
Um, yeah, I know there's a lot of, uh,
examples out there of just simple
daily improvements, right? I have,
uh, an agent that kicks off every morning,
scrubs through my Outlook calendar,
gives me a report of everything, checks the weather,
and just kind of gives me a, a quick daily briefing,
um, things that would take
not a ton of time in the morning, but
just a few seconds
or a few minutes that saves me is, uh,
is pretty, uh, pretty great.
You know, at the, the heart of
every, uh, every AI
agent
is what's called the, the uh the agentic
loop. And this is what really enables
the intelligent.
Uh, autonomous behavior. It's through a
cycle of, uh, reasoning,
tool discovery and selection,
uh, tool execution, and then finally
response generation.
And really it starts with
a prompt, right? So it starts with the,
the information that you're feeding into,
um, into your
LLM based application,
um, that invokes the agent.
The agent then cycles through.
Uh, invokes the model, um,
you know, conducts reasoning to understand what is
this request?
And what do I need to do to satisfy
this request.
Um,
the agent will then look at the
series of tools that are available to it, you
know, like a,
uh, like a carpenter building a
bookshelf, right?
What about, what do I have available? I have,
uh, measuring tape, a saw, hammer,
nails, uh, what have you.
The agent will look at everything that's avail that's available
and decide which tools to use
and when.
Throughout this loop, uh, the agent
will,
uh,
execute each tool,
receive the information back, and then kind of look
back on itself and say, all right, I, this is what I
have, my context has been updated.
What do I need to do next?
Uh, to satisfy this final,
uh, this final end result, do I need to do anything
else? Do I need to use another tool?
And then if so, execute that tool,
bring the information back, and just continue through
that process of execution,
reevaluation until the final
goal is, uh, is reached.
Now, um,
you know, we saw quite a few of you, uh, are using
agents, and using some, some, uh, automated
workflows.
Uh, who here has, uh, has built
their own agent before?
Couple of hands.
Um. You know, is it, was
it easy? Was it a little bit difficult
to get, get started, see some,
some, uh, some head shakes, not, not so easy.
Uh, fortunately,
in July, uh, of this year,
we released, uh, Strand's Agent
as an open source project.
Uh, Strands Agent SDK is
an open source,
uh, Python and now a TypeScript framework
that, uh, dramatically
simplifies the process of,
uh, of building an agent.
And it's um it it's built
on kind of a simple premise
that you should be able to
uh
to build a production ready agent
in just a few lines of code,
right? We shouldn't take you.
Months of coding and
deep knowledge and deep expertise
to be able to
get started and build something to
uh to start testing uh your your
use cases.
Um, you know, strands is
simple to use,
and really eliminates the need for,
uh, for building complex agent,
uh, orchestration,
um, and, uh, and defining
complex workflows,
uh, by actually embracing
a kind of model first
methodology.
Uh, strands rather than
forcing you to define your,
uh, your orchestration and your workload patterns
will actually use
the, uh, state of the art LLMs
to conduct the reasoning
and planning and, uh, and
workflow, uh, uh, workflow
design, um.
It uses everything to to plan,
to change thoughts, to call tools,
and to, uh, you know, kind of reflect back
on uh on what's been received,
and uh what's been re uh achieved.
So,
um,
for those of you that, that watched, uh, Swami's
keynote yesterday,
we kind of mentioned there's 3 components
to every agent.
Um. Does anyone know
what those components are?
I wanna shout out.
Say that again. Resources?
Yep. Any other?
Maybe it will help if you go back to the agentic loop
diagram, maybe it gives some hint.
Yeah, what do you think the agent needs here? What
are the three things it needs to operate?
Yes, model access.
Yep. prompt,
yes, kind of defining the system prompt
and persona for the agent, yep,
and I heard resources or or tools,
tools, right?
Perfect, perfect, so um.
You know, with, with strands,
um. You're
able to use any model that
is, uh, that supports tool usage,
um, that can be, uh, through
Amazon Bedrock
and, uh, using anthropic
cloud uh cloud models,
um, open API, etc.
um, as long as your models
support,
uh, tool execution,
strands, uh, the strands framework, uh,
will, uh, will work and will support
your use case.
And let's look at a,
what a simple agent looks like
with uh using the strands framework.
So we have here
You know, the first thing we need is a prompt.
Um, so we're, we define, uh,
you know, invoking the,
uh, the agent class, we define a system
prompt, just saying,
you're a helpful assistant,
um, you provide concise
responses.
Now, what you don't see here is
a model defined, right? So we, we
do need a model,
but with strands, if you don't
define
uh that model or model provider,
by default, it will uh
it will use Bedrock as your model
provider, um, and we use
anthropic cloud, uh cloud
4 sonnet, right, as your
as your default model.
And just uh
sorry to interrupt if
just so you know, we will actually be seeing the code,
we'll be coding, deploying and stuff.
We're showing you the sample code here. It doesn't mean
this is the only code talk we'll do about,
talk about,
um, so this is,
we cannot show all the capabilities while
doing the live coding today. So these are some of the
capabilities and the concepts
which you want to show before you go into the code.
Yeah, sorry.
Yup, perfect.
Um, so in this example,
it's, you know, pretty simple.
We're essentially creating
a basic chatbot, right?
Uh,
you're, we're not providing any, any
tools right now.
We're just
providing an interface for an
end user to interact with a, with
a large language model.
The agent
will, uh, will invoke the model,
and then get a response based on whatever was, was
passed in.
Now if you take a look a little deeper,
um, you know, this is a code example of
defining your model provider
and your specific model.
Um,
so there are a series
of, uh, supported model providers
with, uh, with strands SDK,
um,
Bedrock,
SageMaker.
Um,
other third party, uh, third
party providers, uh, Gemini,
uh, OpenAPI, and, and more.
Uh, once you define your model provider,
uh, you'll pass in the model ID.
So if you're using Bedrock,
check the Bedrock documentation or
through the CLI or API, you can
get the list of the, uh,
of the proper string for your, uh, for your
model identifier.
Um, and you can further customize
your, uh, how your agent is
using and invoking that model, um,
by introducing,
uh, hyperparametters and
other customizations to, you know, fine
tune your, your specific use case.
Just like you saw before,
uh, the agent will
invoke the model,
and, uh, and get a response.
Quick example I did mention
you can use third party model providers,
uh, other than uh providers other than Bedrock,
other than Sagemaker, um, if your
use case, uh, fits that you know,
in, uh, in Matt's keynote on
Tuesday it kind of emphasized the importance
of
model choice and flexibility,
right, not, uh.
Uh, not every model
fits every use case.
Sometimes there are, you know, there are models
that work,
uh, for certain use cases better than others,
um, you know, maybe it's, it's, uh,
you know, a specific,
uh, type of generation, specific
task, uh, maybe there's a, a
price performance, uh, component.
With strands, you have the flexibility
to uh to make that choice, uh
to tune your agent, and to
configure it in a way that meets your needs
and your use cases uh as you
see fit.
So,
without tools,
um, like I said before, an agent is
just kind of a fancy chatbot.
Um,
it will
receive the prompt, uh, from the end user,
send it the LLM.
There are no
tools, no other external connections
available for it.
So all it can do is, uh,
all the LLM can do is,
uh, use the information, use the, the knowledge
that it has, and return your response.
What you see here
is, you're defining a simple
uh weather tool where every day
is sunny,
um, which is nice. I am based in
the Philadelphia area, and it is always sunny
in Philadelphia.
Um.
So with this,
uh, we're using the tool decorator
uh to basically tell strands that
this is a tool.
Um,
that decorator essentially acts as a wrapper
uh around this Python method.
Um, it will extract some
of the available metadata, uh,
from the function.
Uh,
the, uh, the dock string, if there
are, uh, any type hints,
um, all that information bundles it
up into an open API
compatible spec,
that the agent will then use
to, you know,
understand
what tools are in its toolbox,
and how to use it, what inputs are
expected,
um, and even what the
output format, uh, should be.
Um, so, you know, this is
just one example
of
defining a custom tool.
Um, you know, in this case, we're using a
decorator.
Um, we are, uh, also
passing it in, uh, to your agents. So when
we initialize the agent,
um,
in our code,
we define
what tools are available to it.
Um, you see the weather agent here, um,
which we're defining cust uh defining custom
in this, uh, in this block of code.
Um, you also see,
uh, the calculator,
uh, tool mentioned, uh, in the
code here. Um, this comes from
the, uh, the built-in,
uh, set of tools that Strands has,
uh, uh, natively out of the box.
So you have some,
uh, some pre-built tools available like
calculator,
uh,
local file,
um, uh.
Uh, local file interactions, file system
interactions,
uh, streaming data,
uh, API, REST API, HTTP,
uh, requests, things like that.
Um, but, you know, we're giving it
a, a smaller set of, um.
Uh, of tools available so we can do it's
one, specific task of,
uh.
Math calculations
and weather prediction.
Um,
but,
you know, there are other
systems that we might want to integrate with,
um, in, you know, in a business environment.
A lot of times there can be
hundreds, there can be thousands of systems
that you need to integrate with.
And you know those could use
a variety of different methods.
Some can be
uh the REST APIs, there
could be SOAP APIs,
uh, WebSockets,
SQL, Oracle,
any, any number of things.
Um.
To build custom integrations
for all of those different use cases
and ensure that every model
that you could possibly use,
uh, can
interact with those integrations is, it's a pretty
heavy undertaking, right? Um.
So how do we make that easier?
How can we build integrations
for all the systems that we have,
make them functional,
and make them easily available to
um all of our agents?
With that
The solution is
MCP.
How many of you have heard of Model context
Protocol or MCP?
Nice. How many of you have used it?
OK, so
anybody can tell, tell us like what
kind of problem it solves.
Please.
Go ahead. It
provides a common interface. Murray.
or the model can actually speak
in that language
exactly API.
What, what was the problem before that, if
I can ask?
Those were walled gardens you didn't have access to the guts
of whatever you're interacting.
Exactly.
Thank you for that. Uh,
so yeah, for everybody in the room,
uh, quickly, MCP is an open source
standard
for connecting AI applications. Earlier,
think of it as, uh, microservices talking
with the rest APIs. You need to know the
spec, what method is it a
get or post,
what parameter it needs.
There was a standard, and that's how you communicated
with different microservices. These days, AI
agents need to talk to such tools,
and they need such standards too. And that's
what MCP is. MCP is basically
open source so that every, every tool
provider and every AI
assistant
can talk to each other in a unified language.
Uh,
for example, if, as you can see, uh,
AIA assistant needs access to
sometimes local files, sometimes databases, sometimes
remote.
The remote
service or MCP's tool
for that matter, and you need such,
such common
spec, which everybody understands.
Uh, think of it as like a USB-C port for
AI applications, but why we are talking about
AMCP today,
most importantly is because
In real life applications, any ISP
providers where you talk to the softwares,
and if they are implementing their
service as an MCP server.
How do your AI assistants, if you're building
an AI agent, how do you
talk to them?
So with strands, because specifically we are talking
about strands today, Strands has a built-in
integration with MCP servers.
It comes with all the native
MCP client,
uh, definition, so you don't have
to. Adhere to the spec, go to the
anthropic website and read the spec
and design all those uh hardcoded boilerplate
code, that it does it for you,
and we'll see it in action in our code
today. Uh,
virtually,
uh, as you can see.
Imagine you have
3 on the left-hand side, 3 AI
assistants, and which, which needs to talk
to multiple
service providers or, uh, tools on the right-hand
side. If it is,
let's say tomorrow you add, instead of
cloud core, tomorrow you want to add something else,
let's say Quiro for example,
and that also wants to talk to get or
that wants to talk to Google Maps.
Without MCP,
it will be like M N problem.
With MCP basically it becomes you
implement it once on the server side or AI
assistant side,
and same thing,
the server, the MCP server provider or
the tools provider implements it once,
so it becomes N + N problem rather
than M N problem.
And this is huge. That's why.
Every startups these days,
ISPs are going to this
MCP protocol
way of doing things,
providing their services.
So
Ed briefly talked about how do you integrate
AI agents with multiple tools. Some
are built-in,
uh, strands like
whether API call he mentioned.
Then there was also a custom code, what you
write, Python code, and you do at the rate
tool decorator and that becomes a tool, but
that was still everything was local.
Now with MCP, how do you integrate MCP
tool which are hosted somewhere else remotely,
maybe in your on-premise applications,
servers or EC to or
lambda functions.
How do you integrate those?
So what Strands does is it gives you the
MCP client,
uh, multiple transport layer, it
supports, uh,
STDIO for local connectivity.
Here we are using, uh, streamable, oops.
Here we are using a streamable STTP
client. This is mainly used for having
the stream streamable response
and uh the URL you see is typically
in real world, it will be like API gateway URL
or load balancer kind of URL
fronted by your MCP server. So when your
MCP server is hosted somewhere, of
course they expose an
uh proxy layer, and this is that URL
which you'll see in action.
Once you have the client initialized, just
like any other uh code, this is still a Python
code as you can see.
You this line list tool sync
is basically gives you what all
tools this MCP server provides. Typically
a server does not provide just one functionality.
They provide many functionality. For example, in GitHub,
if you talk to GitHub MCP server,
it doesn't just let you to
get clone, it also lets you to get commit, get
push multiple
features, right? Multiple function calls.
And this list list tool
is basically gives you all the tool,
uh, which AI.
Assistant can understand and call.
And this will help LLM
to decide what tools you need to call and in
which order. And that is how
it is making
the AI agent more powerful, basically.
I think there's also a very powerful feature there
with the, the, uh, list tools function,
um, mainly
if you're building MCP servers maybe
within your own organization and different teams
are building tools to expose to to other
teams. Um,
each team that owns the MPC server,
um, or MCP server,
uh, dude, they just have to update their endpoint,
right? Your agent will dynamically.
Uh, when connecting, we'll dynamically
load that list of tools,
and as new tools or new functionality
becomes available, it will automatically
understand, hey, I have these new features, I
have these new things that I can do. You don't
have to
redeploy your side of the
application, rebuild, uh, uh,
reintegrate libraries or anything like that.
Uh, it's, it's as soon as they deploy and
update that tool list, uh, it's ready for your use
and ready for for integration.
Right. So
now you have AI agents, which is a Python
code. You have MCP server somewhere
running. Um,
we'll show it in lambda today.
Uh, but why we chose Serveless today,
uh, to build this? It can be on
EC2, it can be on, on-premise.
But just like any other application, AI
agents are just Python code at the end of
the day. So how do you want to run it?
You should only run it
or basically pay for it when
somebody is using it. You don't want to run it
on a platform where.
You're paying for 8 hours when nobody is using your
AI agent, right?
So that is where, uh, you have the
paper use
kind of, uh, functionality with
Servalis at the peak usage,
uh, let's say Black Friday, you have an AI
assistant who is helping you to do some shopping.
On Black Friday, you, you want to scale that
high, right? And with Servalis,
it happens out of the box and it
goes up and goes down based on your peak
usage. Again, security
and observability is built in just like you might
be aware of with any other application.
There's no fancy stuff.
It stays with
Sales and the AI assistants,
you get it out of the box.
All the cool matrix is what you get, like
how much time it is taking, what's the duration
if something fails, uh, how do you go and debug
about it. And
this is exactly what we'll be building today. Uh,
so we, as you can see, this architecture has
two blue boxes.
So the smaller blue box,
which one, this is called MCP server,
we might not have enough time to build this, uh, from
scratch, so we have already deployed this
part. So, there's a lambda
function, MCP server, uh,
and this lambda function has a very
complex. Implementation
of MCP server, it can roll a dice.
So,
But the important part is not the functionality
of it. What we are trying to show is, how
do you secure your MCP server. Tomorrow, if you want
to build your own MCP server,
how do you secure it? You don't want any
AI agent agent or assistant to DDoS
it, right?
So that's where
we'll show how you secure it using lambda authorizer.
If you do not pass a proper auth
token,
you cannot call your MCP server.
This is how the real world applications are
implemented these days.
Lambda authorizes is one way, of course you can have
a token and
many other ways of securing it, but
this is one way which we'll be showing you today.
And just a quick show of hands, uh,
who here is familiar with building on, uh,
on lambda or, or has experience building lambda
functions? Perfect.
Thank you so much.
Uh, the second part which will mostly
we'll be building today is
this bigger blue box, which is the
agent using strands. Again,
we will be implementing this on lambda,
uh, fronted with API gateway.
So when the end user is, uh, sending
a request or the user prompt,
this AI agent,
uh, as we saw in the agentic loop,
it will talk to the model. Uh,
of bedrock,
it can be anything. It cannot, it just
doesn't have to be bedrock. It can be Open APAI.
It can be Gemini, anything. That's the power of
strands.
This LLM will help you, will
help this AI agent to come up with a plan.
OK, based on your user request, you
need to call one tool, 2-tool, or
3 tools, whatever is implemented here.
So first tool, let's say if the user is only asking
about weather,
you only need tool number 1, which is built-in STTP_request.
Go to the website, a third-party website,
crawl it, give me the weather.
But if, say, the user request
is not just about tool, but also,
uh, a lot of walking is happening in Las Vegas,
how should I commute today? Should I walk? Should I take
a cab?
So that's where we have a custom tool
called commute advisory, and it will, of
course, check how the weather is.
If it is raining, it will not suggest you to walk
without an umbrella.
If it's raining, you don't want to ruin your, uh,
super stylish gold jacket.
Uh, yeah, of course.
And the third tool, which we'll show today is,
uh, the integration with the MCP tool. So
how this AI agent,
for some reason, if I'm walking, uh,
based on the commute advisory of the AI tool,
because we're in Las Vegas, we need to
roll a dice, at least.
So this is the 3rd MCP tool, which we'll
call today to roll the dice and see how
AI can intelligently do the reasoning
and come up with the steps, which tool to call
in which order,
uh. And yeah, so,
any questions before we dive into the code
for this one?
Cool. I think before we
go into the code, just one last slide
to
go to the workflow. What you should keep in mind before
you see the code so that it makes more sense
when we start building.
I'll take this while you prep over there.
All right, so, um,
yeah, let's look at the example that
we'll be, uh, we'll be walking through,
um, end to end,
uh, it's really gonna demonstrate kind of a simple agent that,
uh, you can check the weather,
uh, determine what you
should wear and how you should, uh, uh,
for your commute, how you should travel,
um, and like Raul said,
because we are in Vegas, we might as well
roll some dice.
So, we'll give our agent
uh a pretty simple prompt. Um,
how should I commute today?
And
we're telling it, hey, I'm in Vegas,
let's, let's roll the dice, gamble
for me, what are my, what are my lucky numbers,
um.
You know, notice we're not saying.
Uh, we're not asking about the weather.
We're not saying,
tell me how I should commute based on the
weather. It's gonna figure that out for us.
Um, and we're, uh,
like I said, we're letting the tool, uh,
we're letting the agent decide
what tools should be executed,
and, uh, and when.
And then based on the information that it's
receiving,
um,
we'll, uh, we can provide it some information
on what a
comfortable range should
be and, uh, you know, good
modes of transportation
for, for different scenarios.
Um, and then,
uh, those two, the,
uh, the weather and the commute will
be built with, uh, custom tool
integration, uh, like we saw before using
the tool, uh, decorator.
Um, and then for the MC,
MCP integration,
we have, uh, the MCP server running
a, uh, a dice roll tool.
Uh, when the agent completes its
loop, executes all the, the, uh,
all the tools available,
uh,
does its reasoning and determines it has
everything it needs,
we should get a result
showing the weather.
And uh and how we should uh
how we should commute.
So let's build,
well. That's
Earth Right.
All right, so
let's take a quick peek
at the.
Uh, MCP server, the small blue box
which we saw in the architecture.
So this is our, uh,
remote third party tool, right?
We're not
building this, uh, this MCP
server directly into our strands,
uh, our strands agent.
It's, you know, running off to the side.
Within this.
Within this code,
um, you know, we have
A
Simple function defined
to parse
our uh our dice response.
This is where,
um, we're basically invoking,
uh, Bedrock as the
uh as the back end to actually execute
sort of essentially random number
generation. Um, this could easily
be some other
API,
some other method that will,
uh, that will generate that, uh,
uh, that response.
Here on line 47,
um, we're building what's essentially
the entry point for, uh, for
our agent.
Um, this is
the tool that the agent will
directly invoke.
Um, we're using,
uh, the MCP tool decorator,
uh, to denote that it's
1, being,
uh, being delivered through
MCP,
and 2, it's a tool.
Within our dock string,
we're giving us some basic information
that saying that this is, uh,
this is a tool that will roll dice.
We'll go through just to answer
your questions, so we are also showing
here Dynamo DB.
We don't need it, uh, here, whatever
we record or roll a dice,
we're storing it, but the idea is
you can use this kind of architecture
to do the state management, uh,
within your MCP server.
Yep, um, and in this scenario, you know,
we're we're storing the,
uh, the result of that, uh, of that dice
roll into Dynamo DB
built into strands. There are other
options for,
uh, for persisting
conversation and, and, and context. Uh,
uh, for, for memory and session management,
so you can use Dynamo DB, you can use S3,
you can use some others,
um, in memory for, uh, you know, for,
for storing that, uh, that contextual
data and reusing across,
uh, across sessions.
Um,
Now one thing we don't
want to happen with this, uh,
this MCP because it is
extremely sensitive. We don't want just
anyone to be able to go out and roll dice, that
would be crazy.
Um, we are with our,
uh, API gateway,
um, using a simple,
uh, lambda-based authorizer.
Um, for those of you who are, uh, familiar
with developing applications on lambda
and using API gateway, this should look,
uh, pretty familiar.
Um, in this case, we are,
uh,
API gateway will send,
uh, uh, uh, authorization
headers, uh, and bearer tokens into,
uh, this lambda function.
The lambda function will,
uh, will parse and validate
the token against our, uh,
against our algorithm. In this case,
uh, again,
super secure,
uh, we're checking to see if our token is
quote unquote good token.
If it's not good token.
Kick it out. It's a bad response. You're not
authorized,
um,
simple use case,
uh, clearly it's you can use any
other, uh, identity provider that
you may have.
Um, most identity providers
that, uh, that have some integration or, or
some, uh, uh, examples with
API gateway or with lambda authorizers
will have a boilerplate code on, uh,
that you can, you can place in here and
have, uh, real security versus,
uh.
Yeah, versus ours super strong.
Yeah, the most secure MCP can ever make.
Um, yep, and then at the end, uh,
once everything is validated
as, uh, as good,
um, or if it is, uh,
if it's denied,
we're passing back the IM policy
of either,
uh, uh, allow or
deny for this particular resource
that gets kicked back to the, the client,
and, uh,
API gateway can determine whether or not it can,
uh, it can move forward.
Yeah. Just like any other
application or lambda function,
uh, you want to test it before you expose
it to any AI agent, right?
So let's quickly
test if this dice roll works
by itself or your MCP
tool works by itself.
Um, so with
So,
in CPR the Anthropic provides a tool
called Inspector, uh, to test your MCP
servers. So once you run that,
It gives you a nice little postman kind
of UI. When
you say yes,
So
So What
it does is it gives you, as you can see, this
nice little UI, it comes out of the box. This is
the very basic way of testing your
servers when you build it.
So let's try to connect
to our dice roll server and see before even
AI agent can talk to it.
Let's see if this works by itself standalone.
Oops, it doesn't.
And as you can see, it says.
A user is not authorized to access this
resource. Any guesses? why?
Not a good token.
Exactly. Did you use bad token.
It is a bad token,
not a good idea. You can't use bad token. Only
good token.
Let's see.
Try to connect again. Cool.
So now,
only authentic AI agent,
which we will build on strands, can call this if
they pass good token.
So what are the tools it supports? This
can support multiple tools,
but right now it is only supporting one tool
called dice roll.
So let's see if if it works.
So I'm not saying one dice. I'm saying in a
natural language, roll a dice. So
we are calling, we have to convert this into
one dice somehow because we know LLM
should be able to figure it out for us.
So when you run this,
uh, tool.
And there's lambda cold start here.
It just once.
So as you can see, we said a dice,
it figured out, oh, you're asking for 1,
and I rolled 2. And because it is just
1, the sum is 2.
If I say
roll.
3 days for me.
It rolled 3 dice
And the sum is 15. So this is the one
functionality which our MCP serve is working,
tools are working. Now let's get back to the
AI agent building part.
So as you saw in the
building agent, there are 3 core components.
One is the system prompt, one is the tools,
one is LLM.
So the system prompt is basically what you can do.
What is your personal agent, you are a doctor, engineer,
uh, travel agent,
whatever you are.
Here we are clearly saying you are weather commute
and dice rolling assistant.
And give some system prompts and the
important thing here is
these are the tools I have access to.
You, Mr. LLM, help me figure
out what
tools I need to call for this particular
request which user is asking me for.
So, and in, in what order?
So once you have that, we start with the base tool.
Of uh STTP request, which is in belt
with strands, and the commit advisory tool,
which is just our custom code. Uh, it
can be based on the weather information, what we get,
uh, you can say whether you should walk or not. It
can be anything. You can just simply say,
He can always
walk in Vegas.
This is not a good idea, but the goal
is, this is your code,
and at the rate tool decorator will make it
a tool, basically, which AI
assistant understands.
So
we'll keep some logical implementation
here, not changing this part.
But now you have custom tool, which is a commut
tool, and now you have one built-in
tool which is a weather API tool. Let's start with that.
We are not calling MCP. Why? Uh,
because what if your remote
ISP providers is down for
some reason. Maybe they're running on some other cloud
which is down.
So in that case, your AI
agent should still be able to work with the limited
functionality. It should not just say, OK, I cannot do
anything because I cannot roll a dice.
So what we are trying to do is if you can connect
to.
remote
server MCP server, sure, I can
add more tools to this,
to the base tool, but if not, I can still
work with the base tools. This is one of the best practices
of making your AI agents
make sure that when you're dependent on the
third party tools you have some proper
error handling,
uh, in place, otherwise your agent
is like confused. Oh, I cannot
call this method.
Uh, I'm useless. You don't want to do that.
Um, so now there are 3 important things.
First, we'll define the,
we'll create an agent. We, for that, it
needs a model,
uh, LLM access. So let's see, and
of course, we'll use white coding. That's cool. Everybody
uses this.
So
We can say, OK, model equal
to Novaro, OK?
Uh, that's fine. I want to use Novaro
model instead of default cloud
Sonnet
4.5.
Then you can say, OK, uh, for
starting an agent, I say, OK, I
need an agent where the system prompt is
what you saw here.
And then model is this
model, which we defined,
and the tools is all tools, which is a combination of
MCP plus uh local
tools. Once you have
all these agents defined, let's make a call
uh to this agent.
Now we have this code in a slice where you're
actually building an agent just with a couple of lines
of code.
So let's try to deploy this.
We have created
some shortcut.
So that it builds, uh,
while it is building.
We are using SAM template
for building, uh, but
anybody knows what SAM is?
Exactly.
So do you have that clicker thing? Oh, sorry,
yeah, no worries.
So what it is doing is, uh, you
can use cloud formation, you can use CDK,
you can use SAM. We are using SAM because it's
easier
for this kind of, uh, demo,
but you can also use Terraform.
That is not the main
thing what we are trying to show here.
So while it builds, what it is doing is it is deploying
your strands-based AI agent on lambda.
It is creating an API gateway in front of it.
And as you can see in this code,
We also give the
URL for the MCP server to connect
to. So this is where we have already deployed
an MCP server. This is the API gateway URL.
Back of it is MCP server running on
lambda, which is the dice roll. All right,
now we have 5 minutes left and we have 5 minutes
to test our AI agent. Let's see if it works.
Fingers crossed,
fingers crossed. I have faith.
All right. So let's do the
individual test first, rather than giving the full prompt
and see if individual tools are working.
Let's just
call test weather. So what it is saying
is, I'm calling my AI agent with this prompt.
How is the weather
in Las Vegas?
And it failed.
Hell. You know what, uh,
I'll just copy this code because we don't have time to
debug, otherwise, I would love to debug with you.
Maybe I miss some.
Syntax here.
What about the, uh, does the dice roll?
Yeah, I would be just.
Try to, no, but it goes to the
strength agent itself.
What was that?
Oh, we
did not make enough sacrifices to the demo gods
today. But
yeah, we still have a few minutes. I think we can
still test it. Uh, any other questions
you want to walk through it?
Let's see.
So this is the total code for creating
an MCP server dice roll. As you can see, it
is like 70 lines of MCP,
sorry, SAM template.
It's very much similar to any other lambda function
or API gateway dynamo AP.
Oh, that's fine.
I don't think I broke the stable,
OK. The,
uh, so with, with, uh, with SAM,
uh, SAM is an extension of cloud
formation,
um, so it allows you
to you know simplify
your your templates a little bit, specially for
you know for serverless uh technology
specifically,
um, so we are in this
template defining just a
simple
API event
with MCP as the path
and
a very simple token authorizer
that's uh.
Reference down here as a uh
as a function.
No
fancy special configurations,
uh,
typical out of the box API
gateway.
Fairly standard.
Yeah We
are just about 10 seconds, 54.
All right,
try that again. Careful of this table.
What's that?
table's a little uh
oh yeah. Seen some abuse
this week. All
right. So how is the weather
in Las Vegas? Let's see if the agent can
figure it out.
So it might be initializing two lambda right now. One is
the agent and one is the
other one.
So what it is saying is today is sunny weather. This
is real time. This is live. If you can maybe verify
from your phone. So this is sunny weather,
54 F,
3 miles per 2nd,
MPH from the northwest wind.
So how about, I know the weather, but
I'm not asking you about the
weather. Just tell me about the commute.
So now,
AI agent will figure out that it also
needs to call
weather API or weather tool
because it, it, it has access to all the tools.
It cannot randomly say, OK, you.
You just bike or walk today. So what it
did was it first figured out the weather.
It says, OK, it's sunny, uh,
no chance of precipitation, so making
it ideal for
walking and biking here. If you choose to drive,
remember to wear sunglasses.
So let's do one,
bigger like, uh,
using all tools.
So let's say if I say test all.
So what the prompt here is, how
should I commit today and also roll two dice, which
we saw in our workflow in the,
in the presentation.
And let's see in the real world, how the AI agent
talks to the LLM
and figures out.
So it says, if you see here, it says
it called three tools
weather, then commute and dice roll. These
are the exact
tool names like dice roll,
HTTP request and commute,
and what is the response? It's saying.
This is the weather.
Based on the condition, you must.
You should commute.
Uh, your commute should be straightforward. Additionally,
you asked me to roll two dicees.
6 and 2 is the total, so
totaling to 8.
So it actually called 32s in the
sequence without us telling
what, what, what to call in which order. So
to answer your question, sir,
this is how it will determine, uh,
and
if you like the.
Session.
So we are asking AI agent,
how was the session because we almost finished it.
So we are asking, uh, will I, will we
get 5 stars from you all? Let's see if we can
figure that out.
What do you guys think? Will we get 5 stars from you
guys? Yeah,
so let's see.
Let's see what the agent says.
I cannot predict the exact review, but I'm
sure it will be amazing. If not 5
stars, at least the agent will give it a solid
thumbs up.
Uh,
keep going and have fun with it.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you and thank you for joining.